指スマ地域によっては異性の dj 子さんちっちのちっちっちっぱるっち
謎と呼ばれているゲームがある指で残忍とでも遊べるゲーム実にルールは簡単である
まず両手をグーにして親指が見えるように前に構える
ゲーム開始順番をきれいその順に ub 生まぁ慣れ
過去数字
というそのタイミングでみんなで親指を上げる
言った数と親指の数が合えば片手を下げる両手を下げられた人の勝ち実に簡単なゲーム
であっこのゲーム
大人数てやるとどうなるのだろうか
ここに一人の男が調整しようとしていた
彼も日本じゃドクター何だ
はぁ
皆さんは指スマゲーム the game ご存知でしょうか
いろんな呼び方があるみたい12-2世の一斉の実地って市場レッツ絶賛
たことっすパターンギンギラギンのっって指砂と呼んでますか
4今回は100人の方にちょっと集まって頂いておりから100人で一枚
ゲームをして何回目でピタッと揃えるのか
もう1回でも育ったらクリアということでちょっと検証的な実験動画を振っております
gonzo 入れました一人でツーリスモ指詰まってるから終わらないと思うのでを
拭いだけが数字を言ってライブに追われるグッズと検証していると思ってよいか
あっ
今回ははつまりじゃないな近くなんですけども
この約100例の皆さんで
izoo
指様が
言い妻が終わるかをその拳そうしたいと思いません
それじゃあみなさまでちょっと蛇酒をやってみたいと思いまー
条例
非常にどうぞよろしくお願いしますん
言い妻
じゃあ goo
うん
ありがとうございますでは主義のよろしくお願いします
4日
って言われましたん
始め誘う134
いやー
端でございます
なんと言いねうん
お世話になります
指まあ
ずん
良いよいだろうじゃあ2系統もよろしくお願いします
ka な愛です
田治米社長114
でがー
いいいいい
存知カーくらいを15度あるんですね
あわせますか
指樹ナーン128家がー
ジャルーン9
中で100円車クールべきです狙えば指時なう
聞いたたち
天童ん
やー
ni
じゃあ oni
ビズなぁ全21
ゲンガー
76分
あー水が逐次よって4強
やるよ
イスマンじゅうじゅう eo いい
宗教お願いしまーす
謙虚でありません
玄関ギャグイージー
car
1みんなせずに
10がー
やるー
10位
湯水なぁじぇじゅジャン拳かー
じゃ芸
21位
ちょっと使い切りましたね
はい
水10回目
指でなちぇる淳一
あとにひどいん
では次のよろしくお願いしまーす
でございましたはい
はじめしゃちょー
110人
元軍
110維持
ん
追ってない思いますね